ただ今は薄暗い
ん
[音楽]
大丈夫だ問題ない
まあまあ入れる程度にしてグーッと3件っていっぽかった
止めてくる移動してくればぁちゃんそりゃしんどいははいというわけで弾み雪を実家に
帰ってきておりまーす
ん松もうすぐがちょっとバタバタしてて
実況に帰れなかったんですけどもちょっというフェスも終わって暇ではないんです暇で
はないんですけどようやくちょっと実家でゆっくりできそうなので帰って来ましたと
いうわけで車変な所に駐車するなと
バーやに怒られてしまいましたなぜば
車の犬からだやっぱりで誰かと一緒に暮らすということはそういうことですよ僕は
一人暮らしではチャー一人暮らしに慣れてしまって集団の生活というものができなく
なってしまってるんで頑張って寝取っ拒絶
保続のいる生活に慣れていければいいなと思います言えて多分
テーマにいるのはそんな長くはいないですよ
ame
えっじゃあねえっどういうことあっ全然向きを変えると音ぴょんのこれ
向きを変えてくるあっあっあ免許じゃあもっと
名言いただきましたねー
うまい具合
もういいでしょ
はい乳尻はバズ信じる信じるぞ
はい
かあさんの十分だった8回打っ
おはよおられまだ大丈夫だよええ
んだぜぱぱーっ
ok
パーフェクトただいまっくすぐらい
[音楽]
ではて買いに行ってきます
の端のほうがアホんとやっとってもいいされる it が実験に書いてきました
年末お正月もちょっとバタバタして実家に帰れなかったんですけど
をちょっといろいろイベントなども一段落と400ちょっと家でゆっくりできそうで
ございますといつもこっそり動画を撮っているという間の実家だとゆっくりしたいので
さすがにちょっと軽い動画になると思います毎日出せるか分からないんですけども曲
よく出していこうと思います
何かなんかいいのないからん
設計で実家にきたから何かこう見てきたよね
中学校の時のバスケ部が写真これ
髪の毛短いなこんな感じですちょっと船長は大きめだな
そんなに長くいれと売れないんですけどまぁ1週間以内くらいかな
では実家でちょっとゆっくりしますじゃな
[音楽]
んぐっ
mature 移ったんだかなる声だけの出演ですありがとう
ありがとう婆さんありがとう
これで僕は
生きることができる